[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich was
typisch türkisch ist bei euch um 20
beamte das ist ein türkischer grieß
kuchen damit zuckersirup getränk wird
weil mir so zu langweilig war habe ich
da noch ein paar mandelblättchen
obendrauf getan und das ganze schmeckt
so lecker also ich kann zu ihr ans herz
legen und ganz viel spaß beim video als
erstes kochen wir den zuckersirup und
dafür brauchen wir drei 100 milliliter
wasser 250 gramm zucker und den saft
einer halben zitrone
jetzt gebe ich das wasser und den zu
kennen meinen top und bringen das einmal
zum aufkochen
[Musik]
nachdem ich das drei minuten köcheln
lassen habe gebe ich meinen zitronensaft
dazu und füllt das in eine schüssel um
es abkühlen zu lassen
[Musik]
und für den grieß kuchen benötigen wir
drei eier 320 gramm gries 80 gramm mehl
120 gramm zucker eine zitrone den saft
und den abtrieb davon 100 milliliter
pflanzenöl 100 milliliter sahne eine
packung backpulver eine packung
vanillezucker oder wann der extrakt
sorgen at gramm mandeln und 30 gramm
braunem zucker
ich gebe als erstes meine mein zucker
und den mann hinter zucker in meine
küchenmaschine und schlage das ganze
dann circa acht minuten lang hält cremig
und gebt eure küchenmaschine da einfach
die zeit denn je cremig es wird umso
schöner wie der miss endergebnis
dann gebe ich noch das öl und die sahne
dazu und verrühren das ganz kurz unter
[Musik]
und zum schluss gebe ich noch die
trockenen zutaten hinein als erstes dem
gries
danach das mehl und dann noch das
backpulver
[Musik]
und nicht zu lange röhren das sollte nur
ganz kurz untergerührt werden
[Musik]
diesen schritt könnt ihr natürlich auch
vorher schon machen jetzt habe ich hier
noch zitronensaft und zitronenschalen
abrieb und das ruhig auch noch einmal
mitunter meint gebe ich dann in meiner
28 zentimeter springform die ich vorher
mit backpapier ausgelegte
[Musik]
o
und auf den teig gebe ich noch die
mandeln und anschließend den braunen
zucker
der kommt jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für 30 minuten
und dieser teil macht mir am meisten
spaß jetzt können wir nämlich unseren
abgekühlten zuckersirup auf den heißen
kuchen geben und gibt wirklich alles
drauf auch wenn es am anfang viel
erscheint aber genau so ist es richtig
und den kuchen denke ich jetzt ab dass
hinab grün und geben anschließend für
vier stunden in den kühlschrank oder in
meinem fall jetzt über nacht und das war
schon mit der zubereitung und der war
bei mir über nacht im kühlschrank und so
sieht der leckere kuchen aus und
beschneiden jetzt einmal zusammen 8
[Musik]